hello fellow Guardians destiny too is
out and one of the fun things you can do
our public events however this time you
can make those public events heroic
which will give you better and bigger
loot for more guys like this make sure
you hit that sub button but let's get
into it in order to enable the Cabal
injection rig baroque you're gonna
firstly need to kill a scion after
killing the sign you're gonna need to
shoot a vent at the top of the rig even
though you're burning make sure to stay
in until you destroyed the vent next
kill Sion number two and then you're
gonna be aiming for another vent this
time it'll be in the middle of the rig
then you're gonna have to kill Sion
number three and shoot another vent
however this vent is at the bottom and
only one of the three panels is actually
open so you're gonna actually have to
run around the rig until you find the
vent that's open because you've lost
some time in transit looking for the
vent you're probably gonna need to use
power weapons to then destroy this vent
once you've destroyed the last vent a
new boss will come out kill him and get
your loot
for the Walker public event to make it
heroic you're gonna need to free all the
Scorch cannons currently they're
shielded and the only way to unleash
them is to get orbs that the Walker
drops in order to get these orbs you're
gonna have to shoot the Walker legs and
make it fall down once it falls down it
drops three balls make sure you put them
into the slots where the scorch cannons
are do it again until all the scorch
cannons are free once you do that it'll
trigger the heroic and another tank will
come down that you'll have to kill for
the Fallen glimmer public event in order
to make it heroic
you'll have to destroy the device that's
sucking in glimmer at each extraction
point once you do this at the last one
you'll have to hold and protect a mound
of glimmer you must protect this pile
until a 100 percent transmission if you
die in the clock runs out on you you
won't succeed in the heroic for the
cabal excavation public event in order
to trigger this heroic you're gonna have
to stand near the drill for about 50%
until you see a cabal ship flying around
when you see that cabal ship make sure
to shoot it down and it'll trigger the
heroic make sure you kill it within the
two times it flies around or it's gonna
fly away once the heroic starts you'll
see a cabal centurion boss kill him get
your loot for the witches ritual public
event in order to trigger this heroic
you'll need to kill two wizards which
will then summon another enemy shortly
after you need to then make sure to
stand on the pads when they are lit and
shoot the shards that are above the
portal you'll then have to kill a giant
Knight with an X for the ether resupply
a public event in order to trigger the
heroic you have to make sure that you
kill every servitor protector the only
hard part is when there are three out at
one time so make sure your fireteam is
ready to burn heavies and supers to
ensure that they all die for the taken
blight heroic to trigger this one you'll
notice that there's a bigger blight ball
that's surrounded by a shield which is
immune in order to damage that immune
blight ball you're gonna need to get a
buck in order to get the buff you're
gonna have to go in and out of the
flight balls that are active you're
gonna see that you have a buff on the
left-hand side called blight receding go
in and out of the balls and keep dpsing
the main ball until you finally destroy
it it may take more than one cycle but
eventually once you destroy it you'll
then trigger a boss The Blank maker once
you kill him you'll
get your looped for the spiral
integration public event in order to
make it her oak not only will you have
to protect the main conduit you also
have to stand on pads like he did during
the vault of glass there are three pads
in total and you'll have to capture each
of them at a hundred percent it's
possible that with two people it'll go
faster
once you've triggered their heroic
you'll see a big Hydra that you'll have
to kill stay tuned the game spot for
more destiny to guides and make sure you
hit that subscribe button if you haven't
already see you guys next time
[Music]